I'm an DK I own k & Associates
investigations I've been doing this as
Kane associates for 28 years
today we're going to do a lineup of six
people we're gonna try to figure out
through some questions which two are
actually dating which is kind of
contrary to what I usually do I'm Merle
the world yeah Rachel yeah and where you
from Massachusetts New York yeah telling
another New York I just moved here last
year and you I just moved here like in
the last six months in that six months
yeah it's a scary why what do you do for
a living
video producer and what do you do for a
living alright I'll take the next two
what's your name bun Donny destiny
destiny
yeah where are you from here holy la you
live here your whole life eighteen which
part la you live in Monterey Park
Monterey Park Burbank what do you do
video producer how do you do
I am a DNP what is a DNP a Doctor of
Nursing Practice oh really
so that's you can actually do
prescriptions and stuff right take it
the next to it which I mean Cheska and
how long have you been in LA I've been
here for a sorry life pretty much your
entire life yeah I was born in the
Philippines but we moved here when I was
like run to I'm Leah hi oh yeah I grew
up in Miami yeah do you lived in New
York trip long vacations long vacation
very long vacation yeah I have lots of
family what is every summer
did you significant other live in New
York right time for time how long ago
that end ok everything like a year ago
they moved here yeah
for years you did do you live with your
full-time significant other yeah know
where it is that person look like maybe
30 minutes from where I live you live in
Burbank I do so that's a big part of the
valley that could be anywhere
you're being very invasive China and how
about you do you live with your
significant event no never no no I have
before I don't right now I know neither
one of you lived with your significant
other so who else lives there just all
by yourself you have a dog I do every
cat you don't what kind of animals do
you have what kind of animals have a dog
doesn't it means Buchi because my mom
maintained okay you guys could all be
lying that's true exactly that would be
very nice would it so anyway I know
you're not dating I have a couple ideas
but honestly I'm not there yet because
everybody's lying to me five kids fish
five cats cater out you don't have any
nobody does anybody know her dog's name
nobody knows the dogs am does anybody
know her dogs am I'm very good
does anybody know the poodle terriers
name yeah do you know Kay what is it
fetch couch your mom named it how are
you even dating your significant other
three or four years how are you been
dating your significant other at the
same time about the same
on the anniversary so how did you decide
which date it was you two aren't
together we already know this we know
you two aren't together we know you two
aren't together we know you and her are
together is your girlfriend you know yes
sorry but we are we already knew dawn
was out anyway it didn't matter
everybody's lying every single person
wears life they can't keep their life
straight and if two of them are actually
dating that they need to look elsewhere
because they know nothing about each
other I think just based on some of the
interaction between some of the people I
can tell certain people aren't with
certain people it's trying to pick the
two that are actually together so gonna
be a little bit more difficult look at
the way you guys are sitting I'm also
sick I did she did tell me this morning
really yeah Wynette coffee yeah yeah no
the two that are together I don't know
that I've actually had sitting together
because I haven't seen any interaction
that makes me think that yet I don't
think those two are together Rachel
Rachel could be dating somebody in this
room I could be and if it's so good she
I think Cheska's part of the couple did
you meet your girlfriend in New York
yeah you said that because you have to
keep going back and forth disappear
there yeah and then she just moves you
recently yeah can we bring Leah back one
last time you can say each other before
today
weekend there was lots of pride events
so she had to go to a lot of private
pride events private private events no I
just like sputtered what pride events
did you go to
what's he giving right yeah what else do
you do I mean you ever when you go out
you just go to bars you like to cook in
turquoise she likes to cook I just like
standing what is killing a babe this
smells nice babe listen hos nice house
what you do you didn't live in New York
did you know ever yeah is that true
that's true
you got a high school in Philippines
didn't think so how would you you are
what branch
Navy what Naval Base were you out in the
Philippines that's good okay Don just
for fun
did you go to Jesuit school home the
Philippines okay never mind
Rachel yeah magic and Jesuit school in
the Philippines did you go to high
school in the Philippines really oh
where did you go the other half New York
and the Philippines half and half for
school
where was it in the Philippine foot city
district geography at high school where
did you go high school for help so are
you lying about the girlfriend here or
are we lying about the Philippines High
School Jesuit school in the Philippine
downtown Philippines downtown on the
American naval base I'm lying about
neither Don come on this could be fun
how'd you end up coming here today why
are you on this set you're the only
person that doesn't work here so why are
you here for the shoot why and cold brew
they have a good canteen how much how
you spend the Philippines wait I never
said it was some Philippines I asked you
how much time you spent that there here
and there where did you spend time in
the Philippines [ __ ] now say boo you
know your Philippines I actually went to
geography bus oh so you know your
Philippines - so he's the only one said
he's got had any experience in high
school in the Philippines and you said
that the for sure the person you're with
went to high school in the Philippines
after interviewing everyone I think it's
Jessica and I'm we're actually married
oh that's not fair
yeah it's because they were all lying so
well and only reason because of the
other people that I put you next to
until I made a comment and you guys
tried to act like you were together it
was yeah I mean that's how I eliminated
anybody else from you